SARA ROBINSON: Welcome back to
the last video in our What-if
Tool miniseries.
In the first video, James
and I gave you an overview
of the What-if Tool.
And in the second video,
we did a deep dive
of the Datapoint Editor.
Here, we'll be focusing on
the Performance & Fairness tab
using the same housing data
set from the last two videos.
This model predicts whether
a house is worth more or less
than $160,000.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES WEXLER: The first thing
we see on the Performance
& Fairness tab are various
performance metrics
for our model.
The confusion matrix
tells us the percentage
of each class our
model classified
correctly and incorrectly.
If we add the numbers on
the top left diagonal,
it will equal our overall model
accuracy-- in this case, 97%.
This shows us that 50 out of 51
data points from our test set
were correctly classified
as over $160,000,
and 47 out of 49 data
points from our test set
were correctly classified
as less than $160,000.
The model had very few false
negatives and false positives.
So far, we haven't changed
the threshold slider.
Sara, do you want to explain
what we can do with it?
SARA ROBINSON: Sure.
The threshold indicates
your model's decision point
between classes.
In this case, any
prediction above 0.5
will be classified as
more than $160,000.
Changing the threshold
is one technique
for optimizing your
model's performance.
To change it in the What-if
Tool, we can adjust the slider.
When we do this, you'll notice
that our metrics change.
In this case,
increasing the threshold
decreases overall accuracy
but also decreases
our false positives.
JAMES WEXLER: If we select
a single threshold from
the optimization strategies,
the What-if Tool will choose
the threshold that yields
the highest overall accuracy
on the loaded data points--
so the lowest total of false
negatives and false positives.
For this model,
it's still a 0.5.
This view shows us how our model
is behaving across all data
points.
But what if we want
to see how it's
behaving across different
slices of our data?
That will help us
understand if there's
areas where it's treating
subsets of data points
differently.
Sara, do you want to show us how
to slice by different features?
SARA ROBINSON: Sure.
Let's try slicing by
garage type attached,
which indicates
whether the garage is
attached to the house.
Notice that houses
with an attached garage
have a higher likelihood that
our model will value them
at more than $160,000.
Now let's imagine that we
wanted our model to price houses
with attached and unattached
garages in the same way.
In this example, we
care most about having
the same percentage of positive
classifications across slices
while still achieving the
highest possible accuracy
within that constraint.
For this, we should
select demographic parity
as our optimization strategy
from the fairness section
on the bottom left.
Notice that our threshold
sliders and accuracy
metrics change when
we set this strategy.
JAMES WEXLER: What do
all these changes mean?
If we don't want
the garage placement
to influence our
model's price, we
need to use different
thresholds for houses
depending on whether
the garage is attached.
With these updated
thresholds, the model
will predict the house to
be worth more than $160,000
when the prediction
score is 0.99 or higher.
Alternatively, a house
without an attached garage
should be classified
as over $160,000
if the model predicts
0.52 or higher.
What about other
optimization strategies?
SARA ROBINSON: We can use the
equal opportunity strategy
to achieve a similar percentage
of correct predictions
across each slice for the
houses in our test data
set that are worth
more than $160,000.
And equal accuracy will
strive for similar accuracy
across both slices.
Finally, one more performance
and fairness feature
we should look at is
changing the cost ratio.
JAMES WEXLER: So far, all of
our optimization strategies
have tried to pick
the best thresholds,
given that we care equally
about false positives
and false negatives.
But this may not be the
case for many models.
For a model used in cancer
screening, for example,
you might want the model to
avoid false negatives, meaning
misdiagnoses, at
the cost of having
more false positives, which
could then be screened out
at the next level of testing.
SARA ROBINSON: To
update thresholds
based on how you want your
model to handle false positives
and negatives, you can
change the cost ratio.
For example, setting
the cost ratio to 4
means that we want to consider
false negatives four times
as costly as false positives.
Then we can find the optimal
threshold, given this new cost
ratio.
JAMES WEXLER: We've covered
a lot in this video.
To recap, we looked
at a few metrics
for evaluating the
performance of a model,
including the confusion
matrix, and true and false
positive rates.
Then we looked at modifying
the prediction threshold
and analyzed how our model
behaved across different slices
of our data.
SARA ROBINSON: Keep in
mind that while this
is a data set of
houses, we'd want
to do a similar
analysis for other types
of data, especially
human-centered data.
It's also important
to note that we've
shown just one strategy for
improving the fairness of an ML
model.
There are many other
methods available for this,
such as augmenting
training data and designing
fairer cost functions
for use at training time.
JAMES WEXLER: For more
resources on everything
we showed, check out the links
in the video description.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]